All right,
so let's really focus on what you've done with them,
Mckayla school that you started in 2014 there was a lot in,
in the research that I was doing about discipline really before you even get to
education.
So you guys do a bootcamp before you get to teach in them anything.
You're actually teaching them some things that purely about discipline and sort
of how to live,
how to behave.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
And that's because we believe if you haven't taught them how to behave,
then you can't give them a detention for it because they don't know how.
And the reason why they don't know how is because we know that elsewhere,
they haven't necessarily been taught,
they haven't necessarily learned that at home.
They certainly want to learn it at other schools.
Um,
and that's because our expectations are really high.
And so we teach them,
we have silence in the car doors for instance.
So that's something people come and they say,
why do you have to be so extreme?
I'll tell you why you have to be so extreme because otherwise you've got kids
fighting in the corridors,
bashing each other's heads against the wall.
Some schools where teachers are scared to walk through the corridors because
it's such mayhem,
you have silence.
Everybody just moves really quickly to their lessons.
You've got change over that takes maybe a minute and a half.
Children aren't losing loads of time from their lessons.
I always say 59 minutes out of every 60 minutes in the lesson.
You've got it at MCKAYLA and we're trying to catch them up.
You know,
a lot of our kids come to us with a reading age of a five year old,
six year old when they are 11 years old.
In fact,
I mean some of them aren't like that.
Some of them are Oxbridge material.
And we'll go to Oxford and Cambridge and some of them need real help so that
they don't leave school illiterate.
And innumerate 20% of the kids in,
uh,
Britain leaves school illiterate and innumerate right?
20% one out of five kids now.
And that's functionally,
so it looks like they can read,
but the cat really re right.
And this is happening all across the country.
Um,
and it's become normal to expect that now none of our kids going to be in that
position because,
uh,
we teach them so,
and we teach them in an environment where the children are able to respect their
teachers.
They love their teachers,
they thank them for,
for the lessons at the end of their lessons.
They say good morning and good afternoon and so on.
And things that you would never imagine.
You know,
in a city,
kids,
you,
you know,
if you have an idea in your head of what needs to see,
kids are like,
you imagine the boys walking with their,
with the trousers down here and that Bob kind of way and,
and,
and girls dressing in a way that isn't appropriate at our school.
None of that exists.
Um,
so you do have a dress code,
right?
Well,
they have a uniform,
a uniform,
and that's normal in Britain.
Everybody has a uniform.
Yeah.
But the thing is we actually stick to the uniform.
So you go elsewhere there,
that ties a down.
The shirts rung tagged,
they look like a mess.
They walk like a gangster.
I'm always saying to the kids,
I mean if they start,
they ever start bopping like that.
I said,
you look like a gangster,
you need to stop that.
Right?
Um,
and they get it.
They say,
yeah,
Miss.
Yeah,
yeah,
I get it.
And then they stopped doing it because we talk about getting into the best
universities.
We want you to get the Ivy League universities to get to Russell Group
universities in Britain and we want you to have,
you know,
you aim for the moon and you'll land amongst the stars.
That's why we think.
Right.
And so they're all really ambitious and they're all working hard.
Why anyone would be against this as a concept?
I don't know.
So when you hear pushback against that,
I guess it's that people think it's like presumptuous or something to imply that
their parents can't do it.
Even if often the parents are failing or,
or the parents just have to work too hard and they don't have time to do the
things that you are doing.
And I think then people think there's a racial element to that.
So if you,
if you even address that,
I shouldn't even have a problem with it itself.
They don't like the idea of us being in charge.
They don't like,
they think being an authority means that we must be Nazis.
I've been called not a Nazi many a time,
which is a bit ironic when you think that what the Nazis would've done to
somebody like me,
but
exactly.
So,
and they don't like the idea of us being in authority and us being in charge.
um,
one we're really key on discipline,
but two,
we want the disciplines so that we can teach them properly.
And this is where you referring to what you said?
Yes.
I was watching you at the Oxford Union and you'd set,
have on how kids need to be taught properly.
And I was,
and you'd said they need to be taught critical thinking and take me to task.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The thing is is that
you can't teach critical thinking,
right?
People are critical in their thinking or independently minded or inquisitive
when they know lots about something.
And it's only by knowing lots.
It's like the 10,000 hour thing.
You know,
you got Malcolm Gladwell,
you've got,
you know,
Steve Jobs,
you got the Beatles,
you spent a lot of time doing something.
You will get really good at it and then you'll be able to break the rules.
But if you're trying to break the rules right,
right away when you don't know anything,
then you end up with kids.
And this is the public don't realize just how bad things are where kids don't
know where Paris is.
You know,
kids don't know in Britain who Winston Churchill is,
you know,
they genuinely,
they have no idea.
And that's because nobody's taught them because people are anti knowledge.
So the grandfather to like the whole knowledge movement is,
is uh,
ed Hirsch and he's an American.
His most recent book is why knowledge matters,
which I would encourage all of your viewers to,
to read.
Um,
you know,
education is the most important thing in any country.
Right.
And,
uh,
and that's one of why I'm so pleased to be talking to you because people need to
realize,
you know,
you,
you can have all your arguments about free speech and about,
about,
I don't know,
guns and about whatever it is you want.
But if the schools are not teaching children properly,
then that is the end of any country.
Right.
And I am desperately trying to shout as much as I can to tell people to that we
need to do something and,
and we are doing something.
I mean,
we're doing something and other people that were not the only ones,
you know,
there are other people who are doing things.
We named Mckayla,
Mckayla after a woman who died of cancer,
who I used to work with and uh,
she and her own classroom used to do exactly this.
And there are teachers all over America and all over Britain doing this in their
own classrooms.
We need,
we need it to be more than that.
We need entire school districts.
You know,
we need people to get this point.
And when you said about teaching critical thinking,
it's a romantic view that comes from Rousseau,
uh,
so 18th century philosopher,
Rousseau and he said,
you know,
a man is born free but everywhere and change this whole idea of um,
of uh,
you education makes you less free.
This is what the,
the,
the progressive thing and actually self control brings you freedom,
right?
It's counterintuitive,
but actually order and structure make you free.
Um,
they allow you to pursue all those avenues of knowledge basically.
Exactly.
The sort of center.
If you learn lots about something,
then you're able to apply that knowledge in different ways.
So I mean,
as an example,
um,
you know,
if,
if you take a math question that a primary school kid might be given,
uh,
you know,
John has 8 cents at the end of the day,
it's one quarter of what he had at the beginning of the day.
How much money did he spend during the day?
Now I think I can do it and I think you can too.
I'm terrible at math,
but I do know,
I think you can do it is because you got short term memory and long term memory
and you've got a whole bunch of math facts in your longterm memory that you're
able to draw out.
You're able to go quarter,
no,
there's four of those in a hole and then you're able to go four times eight
cause I know my four times table and I can take it to 32 and then I can do
subtraction so I can take it to 24 right now if you're seven years old.
However,
if you have to hold all those facts in your working memory,
working memory,
can't do it,
you have got to drill and practice those timetable facts for instance,
and put them into your longterm memory and put those fractions into your
longterm memory so that when somebody gives you something more complex,
you can go Bam,
Bam,
Bam and bring it out and then you've got the answer.
Sadly,
what happens is people say no,
what we need to do is teach them complex problem solving.
Let's give them that first.
You've got to break it down.
What are the bits underneath that you've got to build up from?
And that stuff is a bit boring and because it's boring and isn't very romantic,
this resolved was talking about resale.
So Rousseau,
this idea with you,
you,
you bring it out of the child,
right?
So they have this phrase which says,
you know,
the mind is not a vessel to be filled but a spark to be ignited.
And it all sounds really exciting and thrilling,
right?
And that's the thing.
It's so seductive.
It pulls everybody in.
But the reality is that actually what you need,
there's a whole lot of facts in your,
in your memory there that you can then go boom,
boom,
boom and apply.
Now that doesn't mean that you're just a parrot and you just end up learning a
whole load of facts,
which you then can just regurgitate.
You need to apply them and you need to give children the chance to apply them
and have a class discussion.
And we do paired work and selling often in more progressive places.
They'll do group work,
they'll put five kids,
four kids around the table and they do group work and then what happens is the
teacher moves amongst them as a facilitator of learning as opposed to the
teacher who's driving the bus.
I always say the teacher needs to sit in the bus and drive and the kids get on
the bus with you and go the more progressive way your there just keeping them on
task.
You do that,
let me come and see you.
You do that.
But they learn very much and then they don't succeed and then we say it's
because they were black.
It's cause they were poor.
What we need to do is give them welfare and then there'll be okay cause that
will make them equal.
I my point there is no fix the education system,
give them an education and then they'll make themselves equal.
Yeah.
Gosh this reminds me of,
so I mentioned that I'm not that good at math and I remember the day,
I haven't thought about this in probably 1520 I don't know,
maybe literally maybe 20 years.
I remember being in sixth or seventh grade and we were doing division for the
first time.
Yeah.
And I remember the teacher gave us a,
we had a quiz or something and I was able to do it in my head and I,
so they had,
you know,
the the equation and I just wrote the answer and she gave me a fair,
I failed or I got a zero or something,
even though I had all the answers.
Right.
And she said,
you didn't show your work.
Oh,
and I,
and I remember Seder,
but I got all the answers right.
And she said,
no,
I need to see how you do work now.
I didn't know how to do it that way,
but somehow I was able to do it in my head.
And I remember thinking that if that was all necessary to show the work,
that at some point I would get to a place where I would have to do it.
But somehow I had figured out my little trick first.
But because of the way she kind of just failed me for it,
he completely turned me off.
Man,
I literally haven't thought of that in probably 20 years or something.
That's a total sidebar all together.
But I guess it just goes to show that we all,
we all kind of learn differently and you need teachers that can kind of embrace
the way you do it a little bit rather than just jam it down your throat.
Yeah.
Well you,
you,
which is probably a little bit of the,
the progressive thing that you don't like in a way.
Yeah.
What I would say is you remember that particular incident and think that's all
it was,
but I guarantee you that how'd you been taught properly in that classroom?
Uh,
you would have known her methods.
Yeah.
He would've known what to write down.
You didn't know what to write down because there was too much chaos in the
classroom.
You weren't listening,
you were busy talking to your friend because she let you talk because she didn't
have high enough standards of behavior.
Right.
And so yeah,
that sounds right.
Yeah.
Well and that's it.
Cause this is just standard.
This is just what happens in all classrooms.
And then people think,
you know,
it's mean to make kids behave.
And after a while,
the thing is,
is that remember there's more of them than there is of us,
right?
So we're not actually making them do anything they want to behave.
We're just creating an environment where they're able to do it.
That's all.
Um,
now there's,
there's the,
there's the 10%.
There's the 10% on the outskirts that the detentions or so and keep them in
line.
Right?
Um,
but the vast majority,
you need that tipping point.
The vast majority buy into what we do.
And if you come visit our school,
the kids will say to you,
yeah,
it's super strict and yeah,
we get detentions,
but you know what?
I get a great education and that's what I want because I want the opportunity to
be able to change my stars.
And if you believe that,
if you believe in equality of opportunity,
which sadly I think too many people in education don't believe in equality of
opportunity,
um,
if you do,
then you want to provide an environment where they're going to be able to do
that.
And,
um,
and,
and that's what we do and,
and I,
and I really hope those teachers would come and visit us that they were able to,
to,
to take from that and,
and,
and do something in their school.
Yeah.
Well,
first off,
I told you before we started,
I'm going to be in the UK with Jordan Peterson for a couple of stops.
So I will do everything I can to stop by and maybe I can get Jordan to swing by.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I know that his daughter is Mikayla by the way.
So there's really deep,
powerful thing happened that is even powerful.
Um,
what about the type of kids you,
you've mentioned that there's some diversity in the type of kids that are coming
in.
How do you guys decide who actually can,
can cut it and who can afford it and other,
you know,
all that?
Well,
it's not up to us who comes to us.
Uh,
it's the local council that kind of send kids to us.
so we do,
they decide who goes,
well,
it's a lottery
and people apply and then they get picked out of a hat literally,
and then,
and then they come.
Um,
some of the people,
you know,
some of the kids who end up with us didn't even necessarily want to be with us.
Uh,
they just end up being pushed towards us because that's the way the system goes.
I mean,
frankly,
I don't even understand the system,
but we get a bunch of kids.
We've got 120 kids in every year.
So it's a pure lottery to go to the school.
Yeah.
And basically if they don't win the lottery,
so to speak,
they're just going into the public school because at that point,
most likely the parents can't afford a private school.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
definitely.
The parents can't afford a private school,
but there's no,
I mean,
you talk about it as if we're different.
like we're just another school.
There's loads of schools like us in that sense around.
Um,
I mean we are a free school,
but,
uh,
yeah,
it doesn't,
it's not like we're the free school.
And then there's the local public school,
there's loads,
there's lots of schools and um,
and parents will choose us if they want to.
Um,
and as I say,
sometimes we end up with,
with,
with kids because the system is such that you have to choose your top five
schools and you know,
you chosen us fifth,
he probably don't want to be with us,
but in the name of fairness as,
as it always goes,
the people who have chosen as fifth has just as much of a chance of getting in
at the people who've chosen this for x and got very American there.
And did it cause it,
cause I grew up in Canada,
so you know,
China changes.
Um,
but yeah,
so people who don't want to come to us come to,
and people who do really want to come to us,
come to us and look,
you know,
I called myself the dragon lady and I say,
you know what?
I'm not going to change.
And if you're happy to put up with me,
these are the rules and this is what we do.
So if we hear your phone or if we see your phone,
we'll take it and we will keep it for up to 16 weeks.
And that's the way that it is.
Um,
you know,
these smartphones are killing kids.
I wanted to get there.
Yeah.
Where do you make of that?
Because it's an,
it's a disaster.
And in 20 years people are gonna know,
you know,
when I say it now,
people say,
Whoa,
you're being extreme.
You know,
some schools,
they actually have these phones out in lessons.
Uh,
lots of schools.
They have the mountain corridors and in the yard and so on.
We have them banned completely.
And I'm even trying to get parents to take them away at home.
We know we sell brick phones.
So a phone that you can't access the Internet.
Uh,
so that we try to encourage parents,
give them that you want to keep in touch with their kid.
Fine,
I understand.
But you don't need to give them a smartphone.
And the access to the Internet.
You know,
Steve Jobs,
Bill Gates,
all of those big guys in it,
they don't give their children phones until they're 15.
They keep them away.
When Steve Jobs in 2010 and the iPad came out and he was interviewed and they
said,
what?
What did you think about?
What does,
what are your kids think about the iPad?
And he said,
I don't know.
I wouldn't give my kids the IPAD.
He,
his,
they protect their children.
Meanwhile,
our parents have no idea they're,
they're saving up for months that give the kids this Christmas present.
And it's,
it's,
it's like giving them heroin.
I say it's like playing Russian roulette,
you know,
um,
who did you give anybody access to your child on this phone?
Right?
Weirdo out there knows who your child lives knows where.
How did they go to school?
Knows where they go to school,
knows who their friends are.
They get,
I mean,
I don't understand.
Well,
the reason why people do this is because they don't know and they don't think
about the dangers,
not just with random people,
but also lovely girls who get involved with the bad boys at school.
Um,
bad boys who might be criminals elsewhere,
etc. And they quite liked them and they wouldn't otherwise know them.
But oh you maybe he's going to add me on snapchat.
Whoo.
You know,
and this is the kind of,
it's terrible.
What about just for attention spans?
Cause I would imagine you're dealing with a lot of that for people right now.
Cause massive problems.
Snapchat as you just said.
Exactly.
So you know,
before when they used to watch,
you know,
Dallas and dynasty and so on,
at least there was a narrative arc that went like this and it told a story and
then something bad happened and then it gets resolved and so on and doesn't
happen anymore.
You've got like 22nd I went to the hairdresser's look at this man's head.
Ooh,
end of the little ditty that,
that's what they're watching,
right?
It's terrible.
So smart phones are a huge problem for the inner city.
And the biggest problem I would say a progressive teaching methods that have
infiltrated our schools and sadly this kind of re so an idea that you're drawing
something out of the child as opposed to putting something in and the way in
which over the last 50 years we have turned away from knowledge,
um,
as being really important.
This hits of course the most vulnerable.
So working kids,
uh,
in,
in our country,
you know,
that tends to be a black thing in this country,
in our country.
You know,
in,
in Britain it will be black kids,
but it'll also be white working class kids.
It'd be a variety of different kids who get hit by this because if you are from
a richer background,
your parents,
you know,
you sit around the dinner table at night and you have dinner and you talk about
the politics of the day and you learn about different countries and on science
and all sorts of things.
Just through talking to your parents,
onto your parents,
friends and your uncle and your aunt and so on with kids whose parents are not
well educated,
they don't get that at home.
So they're depending entirely on the school to give them what they need to be
able to succeed.
And sadly,
because schools are convinced about this idea of this romance around,
um,
thinking critically and,
and,
and that's not to say we don't want them thinking critically.
We do.
Yeah.
But you need to give them lots of stuff to get them to that.
Right.
So,
so when I said that at Oxford Union about teaching critical thinking,
it's not that you don't believe in critical thinking,
of course it's that you really,
that's not,
that's not something to teach,
at least at first.
It's that you have to give them all the,
the breadth of knowledge first and then they will learn how to critically think
about overplays issues.
Fair enough.
I like tickets and criticism.
Exactly.
I agree for yearly and it's,
it's something that we're just,
you're having to fight all over the place.
And,
and it's that idea of giving them that equality of opportunity,
you see,
uh,
which is what I call,
I keep coming back to because,
um,
instances where this doesn't work.
I mean,
have there been kids that come through and just for whatever reason,
this,
this concept that,
that you've built,
that you're instilling in all these other students,
it just does not work for them either because of something about them or the
family or,
yeah.
So I've had to exclude a few children for knives.
You know,
that that is something in the inner city.
That's a problem.
You know,
when we talk about in the city,
you know,
we've got kids showing up,
young men showing up on bikes with masks,
carrying knives,
waiting to meet some of our kids.
You know,
this,
this is the inner city.
So there are,
uh,
some of those issues that can take over,
you know,
but,
um,
but that doesn't mean that it hasn't worked.
It always works.
The kids always learn more than they've ever learned anywhere else.
The kids always are stunned by their own intelligence and what is possible.
Um,
because we show that to them and it's,
um,
you know,
and,
and what kind of breaks my heart is that even those who are conservative,
so you ever,
I watched all your programs and you have all these great people that come on,
but nobody ever talks about education.
You're Larry Elder,
for instance,
who I love and I think he's brilliant.
Yeah.
You know,
he talks about all these things play in the black community and he has all this
stats that he always comes out with.
And there's that thing where he takes you apart,
you know?
Um,
ignore my real moments.
Yeah.
But what,
but what he doesn't do,
he talks about absent fathers,
talks about crime,
talks about drugs and so on,
but they never talk about education.
And the thing is education.
That's our black people's fault,
right?
That isn't that the state.
Right.
And the state needs to be held to account for this because we spend in Britain
80 billion pounds a year on the state education system.
And yet we are failing all of our kids.
And that isn't right.
We,
we and,
and Laurie older and all of these people who talk,
they need to be able to say,
now,
wait a minute,
there's something going wrong at a very low level because you can,
you can talk all you want about personal responsibility,
but if you haven't got an education,
it's very hard to make anything of your,
so is the problem then that in,
at least in the American context,
the answer always is throw more money at it.
So it's not the,
the real answer,
which obviously we've spent 45 minutes talking about,
which is why and how you have to clean up these schools.
But the easy answer is always throw more money at it if they just need more
money.
You know,
you always hear these things,
well,
they don't have enough pencils and they don't have enough,
uh,
you know,
other supplies and notebooks and things.
And then people don't take the next step,
which would be the critical thinking,
step up the whole thing.
Yeah.
It's not about money.
You can throw money at anything yet.
The irony is they all go on about critical thinking.
They're not doing any critical thinking,
you know,
if only they would.
But,
um,
I,
I wish you luck.
I mean the,
the,
the left really,
I refused.
They refused to recognize there's even a problem.
Uh,
the right,
we'll recognize that there's a problem,
but they don't talk about it.
So that's what I'm saying about the people who you interview and so on.
I just wish more people would say actually the solution is an education,
uh,
because it really is,
the,
the black community for instance,
um,
you know,
would,
would transform if they were given,
uh,
the opportunity to have a great education.
Um,
and,
and that's not to say that all of the things that Larry elder talks about,
about absent fathers and so on aren't a problem.
Right?
I mean they are absolutely.
Uh,
but it's really important to call them out on it.
And it's really important to call out.
You see,
and this is where I would disagree.
You know,
I consider myself a conservative and the black conservative,
but I would disagree with some of the black conservatives out there who refuse
to recognize racism as a problem at all.
You know,
they kind of just dismiss it.
And I would say no,
it is a big problem.
And the reason it's a big problem is because the left in so many ways are
racist.
You know,
when they want to own us and they want to tell us how we can vote and they want
to tell us how we can think that is racism.
And when they refused to recognize what works in education that's going to help
poor kids,
black kids,
you know,
white working class kids in Britain when they refuse to look at that.
Well that's racist.
And I'd say it's racist against the white working class.
The way the white working class was spoken about in Britain is the way that
sometimes black kidney,
the black communities have spoken about in America,
which is like there's some kind of different,
they're like they're aliens.
Oh well,
you know,
that's just the way they are.
No,
that's not the way they are actually.
If you give them the opportunity,
but you will want to sit around dinner parties and talk about how kind you are
and how great you are because your virtue signaling and voting on the left,
you know.
Um,
and I just wish,
I suppose that there were more conservatives who were speaking out about this
and saying something.
Um,
I guess there's a weird reflex for them where they've been called racist for so
long,
even though often they are minorities.
Yeah.
Where they don't want,
I see this,
I definitely see this.
Yeah.
Where they don't want to use the same tactics.
So what you just said,
right.
There is such a flip on the way we think of racism.
I tend to agree with that line of thinking obviously.
But yeah,
the people that are screaming about racism are all the time.
Now are the people who are racist,
who are racist.
They really,
really are.
And I don't say,
I don't say that lightly because I don't like calling people racist,
but they are the ones who are demanding.
I look at everyone based on race and sexuality and the rest of this,
now we have to call it out.
But I think there's a hesitancy from at least from sort of where I sit because I
don't want to become what they became.
But no,
but I know,
I know you're right at the,
at the core of this,
and look,
I understand you don't want to say everything is racist,
but when there is real racism,
you need to point it out.
Yeah.
And you know,
the fact is that the fact is that if we don't call it out,
all of these kids are going to keep failing.
Ryan.
Uh,
what we don't realize is that all these kids are going through school and being
taught,
uh,
to make sure that they're going off and voting on the left.
That's how it is like that,
that is that,
that's how everyone thinks,
like it's,
it's,
it's so standard in the education,
you know,
system to,
to think on the left that the few conservative teaches that there are out there.
Um,
they're quiet.
They never say anything cause they're terrified.
Right.
Um,
there was no balance of Ford.
and,
and that's really scary I think.
Uh,
and,
and for the future of,
of,
of our countries we,
we need people to talk to each other.
The stuff that you're always talking about,
about talking to each other and sharing ideas and thinking about how the other,
the other side thinks.
Um,
and,
and I worry that,
uh,
w we don't,
we don't do enough of that.
We,
we,
we don't,
we don't do enough of that at school,
that's for sure.
And then those kids turn into adults eventually don't they and them and then we
just,
you know,
well I don't know that then they're really pissed at the system that they
believes failed them and then they just perpetuate that through the next
generation two.
And then eventually that's unsustainable actually.
Cause then you have enough people that are turning against the system that's
failed them.
Yes.
It's because no one stood up and did what you're doing.
But it's interesting because this is where a good old American classical
liberal,
and I know you guys,
at least in the UK have a better understanding of what classical liberalism I
think that we do here.
We talked about this a little bit before that these ones won't getting muddled
and mangled and all that.
Uh,
but this is a place where,
to me,
where the government should be involved.
I am all for using tax dollars to do the things you're talking about.
Where some,
I think,
I think there are plenty of people that are American conservatives at least that
want to just cut funding from all of these things and endlessly quite funny.
As I said,
I'm not for throwing money at them just because that's just the easy answer.
But yeah,
let's figure out how do we wisely use money to empower these teachers?
And that sounds like that's exactly what you're doing.
Well,
exactly.
Um,
it's,
you know,
it's the power of bad ideas at the moment that over the last 50 years,
60,
70 years ago,
uh,
the schools that were out there,
we were more like our school now.
Um,
it's just that things have changed so radically where knowledge has been
sidelined.
Uh,
it's all about skills.
People talk about skills and drawing it out of the child,
like I was saying.
And um,
we've,
we've lost,
um,
we've lost the purpose of education and we've lost,
you know,
the ideas that we have about,
um,
perseverance.
Uh,
even when it's difficult,
especially when it's difficult personal responsibility.
You know,
if you didn't bring in your homework,
then you are responsible for that.
Whereas elsewhere they'll say,
oh,
well,
it's not your fault.
You come from a difficult family,
difficult background.
We're going to give you an excuse.
And if you're constantly being given those excuses,
and if later on getting into university,
there were quotas,
and if you're likely to get in because you're black or your need there,
there's,
there,
there are things that allow you,
oh,
I ticked that box.
I'm going to be able to get,
get in with a lower score,
then you stop setting those standards for yourself,
right?
Yeah.
And then we don't,
we all
eventually degrade the whole system.
If you let someone in at a lower level and then also let them get a job at a
lower level or get into Grad school at a lower level of the job,
at a lower limit.
Everything else.
Yeah.
Well now,
whatever you've created as a professional is,
is a degraded version of whatever that supposed to be.
That's right.
And,
um,
and that is what's happening,
sadly.
Uh,
there's a whole campaign at the moment in Britain for this to happen with Oxford
and Cambridge University,
uh,
to,
to essentially,
uh,
allow kids.
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
it's really sad.
And the reason why is because they say,
hey,
look,
there aren't that many black kids,
uh,
at Oxford and Cambridge.
We need to fix this.
We do.
I agree.
We need to fix it.
So we need to fix the education system.
We need to fix our schools and make sure that they've given that equality of
opportunity.
Not,
not,
well,
I'll tell you,
that day that I spent at Oxford was such an absolute joy and talking to so many
kids just in the streets and,
and just everybody was so like excited to learn and obviously they were
sympathetic to a lot of the things that I talk about and,
and all that.
I'm curious,
so I get it sort of on the sciences and math and that you really want to teach
them the facts on this stuff on things like history.
Yeah.
A lot of the facts in history.
No,
no,
no.
There are facts in history,
but I wonder now these days where it seems like young people are kind of into
socialism or young people are kind of into communism or Marxism,
abreast of it.
Uh,
have you found that teaching history has become oddly,
I was going to say,
oddly political.
I mean it,
of course it is political,
but oddly politicized.
Yeah.
So like Hitler for instance,
has taught to death.
Um,
but,
uh,
say the,
the trustees of communism and so on are not taught so much.
Um,
or even then,
so rarely is,
is,
is so little is taught full stop because they're not being taught properly in
classroom because you are facilitating learning and kids are just teaching
themselves.
I mean that,
I can't stress how much of that is actually going on.
Um,
so yes,
things are politicized and,
um,
children are not able to access the kind of education that they were able to
access before.
And it's hard because I'll say that and then people will just deny that that's
what's going on.
Um,
but you can see by if you talk to university kids at university and asked them
what do they know about the world and so on,
what do they think they'll tell you?
And you'll see how much they've been taught,
what they've been taught at school.
Uh,
so a few of them have an understanding of communism and what it is.
Um,
and that's because they're not learning it appropriately at school.
school is
sadly,
it's,
um,
I wish that there was more diversity of thought amongst teachers.
So one of the reasons why we watch a lot of you the Rubin report is because I
want my staff to try and think outside the box.
What I always say is I can predict everything that you think about every issue
out there.
So if I know that you definitely voted,
remain as opposed to Brexit,
um,
with regard to the European and for us,
or,
or if I know for sure that you would vote for Corban that the leader of the
Labor Party in Britain or if I know,
um,
you know what you would have to say about a whole variety of different things,
even what newspaper you read,
if I can make all those predictions,
there's something wrong.
Cause you know,
with me,
I'm conservative on some issues,
but I'm,
I'm anti guns.
For instance,
I'm pro choice and pro gay marriage,
all sorts of things that I'm very much on the left on.
But there's other things that I'm more conservative about,
you know?
Um,
and that's because I'm a thinking person.
Yeah.
A classical liberal.
I suppose in many ways,
one might say that,
um,
you know,
I'm,
yeah,
the point is I just want people to think outside the box.
Right?
And I wish teachers would,
and that there was more diversity of thought and there is some diversity of
thought,
but they have to keep quiet because they're terrified.
You get the right teachers.
Well,
in a way it's,
it's self selecting.
So when they apply,
um,
there are already people who are,
who are somewhat thinking outside the box.
Um,
and then they,
um,
and then they come.
And I think being at the school also changes their minds about things.
Uh,
they start to think differently,
uh,
because they're seeing what's possible.
Uh,
people can't imagine what's possible within a city.
Kids until they come to our school.
I have visitors,
teachers who are visitors,
they're nearly in tears and saying,
we can't believe that these kids are so nice.
Um,
so that's,
that's what we're trying to do.
And the point,
the PR,
and it happens here,
you know,
I've been to see a,
so I said Ed Hirsch,
you know,
some of the schools where they use his materials and they placed knowledge at
the heart of their curriculum.
I've seen some of those schools in the Bronx and in,
um,
in,
in various but queens and so on.
And,
uh,
and they're doing a great job too.
Um,
I just wish more of it was happening and that we can,
we can get a bigger platform to talk about it because it's just so important.
Um,
but people don't,
people don't get that.
They don't get that story.
You think so?
Yeah,
I do.
I think that's why these types of things are working.
That's why you're half a world away,
you know,
thousands of miles away.
And you've shown this,
the conversations that we're having here to your staff.
Yeah.
And Yeah,
the amount of people that are showing up to these live events now,
the amount of people that are downloading these podcasts and all that,
it's starting
to happen at least.
Yeah.
Well,
I hope so.
I mean,
uh,
there's,
there's so much to be had,
you know,
I've known tens of thousands of kids.
People often say,
why do I do what I do?
Because I've known tens of thousands of kids who could have been so much more,
right,
who could have been in a position to change their stars?
And they weren't able to because the state is spending so much money on their
education and isn't able to provide them with a decent education.
Um,
and that's really sad.
All right,
one more for Ya.
Yeah.
I want you to offer,
so I know that I have a Lotta young people obviously that listen to this show,
high school,
sometimes junior high school,
but college,
whatever else,
just for the general young person out there that's watching this,
that's in a school that's not doing these things,
that's trying to figure out how to learn and think critically and get a good
wide breadth of knowledge.
But the situation that they're in is not everything you've offered here.
What,
what would you say to them to just start doing it for themselves?
You got to take personal responsibility.
So you can't be a victim.
Um,
you know,
the whole victimhood thing is just stoked all the time in schools and uh,
and indulged you.
You got to think,
it doesn't matter where I am a great,
I haven't had the best luck,
right?
I would've loved to been able to go to that local private school,
but you know what?
So what I'm gonna,
I'm gonna sit down and I'm going to work.
I'm not going to work really hard and I'm going to go to the library and I'm
going to find the books and I'm going to teach myself if necessary.
And I've known kids like this who have done this,
um,
I'm known colleagues of Mine and people who I've known,
they just,
they,
they make it their business,
the teach themselves what they need to know and they need to know that knowledge
is at the heart of it.
You need to know lots of stuff and then you can manipulate that stuff.
Um,
and then you can be intelligent with that stuff.
Right?
Um,
you can do it.
You can.
The thing is,
is that it's rare that a 15 year old takes it upon themselves to do it.
They are,
by definition,
they're exceptional.
Most kids need somebody to guide them.
And if their parents aren't doing it,
then I think the school certainly can do it.
Whether or not the school should,
there are people who will say,
well,
it's not fair school shouldn't have to do that.
The parents should do that.
And it's true.
And you know what,
if,
um,
if welfare,
we're not as generous as it is and so on,
the parents probably would have more agency and self determination about
themselves and the incredible catch 22.
Yeah,
they would take more responsibility and they would do something.
And sadly the state hits them in both ways,
right?
Because it gives them the heroin,
a welfare and then it suppresses them by not giving them a decent education.
Uh,
and then they sit around and I talk,
oh,
and I say,
Oh,
I'm a really good person because I believe in giving people loads of welfare and
in having terrible education.
I mean,
how,
you know,
you punch somebody on one side,
then you punch them on the other side.
How on earth are they meant to succeed?
Right?
Um,
and the thing is,
we spend a lot of money in tax to,
to have a state and I'm a classical liberal,
so I believe in a small state,
but we do have a state,
let's use it for what we can for the,
for the good.
Yeah.
Um,
but we're not doing that.
and,
and that's what's,
that's what's really scary.
And,
um,
we,
we need a soul believing in this idea of equality of opportunity and that,
uh,
teaching children's self control,
we'll make them free.
Um,
and,
and having,
uh,
an ordered environment where children can learn,
will,
uh,
enable them to learn lots of stuff so that they can then be motivated to do
something with their lives because they will make themselves free,
um,
by,
by grabbing that opportunity.
And,
and,
and it's that agency,
it's that sense of self determination that the conservatives,
people on the right,
right leaning tend to believe in more as opposed to mummy state coming in and
looking after it for you and taking care of you.
Because if that's what you aspire to,
then what's the point of living?
Right?
Um,
but you know,
you have to teach dead white men,
right?
Like one of the big problems we have is that they don't want to teach dead white
men because they're dead white men.
And that's a problem,
right?
So they only want to teach.
Recently we had the situation where I'm in Manchester,
these students painted over a mural of Kipling.
So Rudyard Kipling's poem was up there and they painted it over and put my
Angelou's poem by Maya Angelou.
And now I'm a great fan of Maya Angelou.
I think she's brilliant.
Um,
but one of the reasons why she's a great writer is because she read a lot of
Kipling and she read a lot of Shakespeare.
In fact,
she said of Shakespeare that she thought when she first read him that he must
have been a black woman because he would have no,
he,
oh,
he had to be a black woman to have understood the plight of black women.
Right.
Because he speaks to the human condition.
Um,
but he's a dead white male.
Oh,
we don't want to teach him.
Co Kipling.
He was a racist.
We don't want to teach him,
but at our school,
we've got them reciting,
you know,
the poem,
if you can keep your head when all about you are losing theirs and blaming it on
you,
you know.
Uh,
but at the end of it,
at the end of it,
it says,
uh,
the earth is yours and everything that's in it.
And what's more,
you'll be a man,
my son,
and that you'll be a man,
my son.
But what about the women?
How,
how can you not be recognizing the women?
And in a day and age where men can be women and women can be men,
we can't allow this possible.
He's obviously speaking to me too,
but there's outrage.
Oh,
no,
no.
He's only mentioned men,
right?
Um,
it's the most beautiful poem.
Our children learn it off heart,
right?
But children elsewhere will never have access to Kipling.
Now everyone needs has to be taught about talk to taught Shakespeare.
You're gonna come by law.
You have to be taught Shakespeare.
But the fact is we indulge in Shakespeare,
we love Shakespeare because Shakespeare is so beautiful and extraordinary.
I'm just cause he's a dead white guy.
Well,
does that mean that he didn't write beautifully?
You know,
they're,
they're just some beautiful,
I mean,
you know,
love is not love,
which alters when it alteration,
finds or bends with the remover to remove.
It's all so beautiful.
And you want the children to be able to access this.
And we teach them other poems like Invictus,
which means an unstoppable.
And when it was one of Mandela's favorite poems,
um,
and you know,
they say at the end,
I am the master of my fate.
I am the captain of my soul.
And all of our kids put their hands on here when they say I on the master of my
fate.
And there's nearly 200 kids in the lunch hall Olis belting this out and loving
it because they are the masters of their fate.
Um,
and it's teaching the kids that and inspiring them to make a difference with
their lives,
whatever their color as opposed to saying,
oh,
well there's racism and sexism in the world,
therefore you're never going to be able to succeed.
Um,
because then you have to give up and don't worry because there's welfare.
So you can always just,
you know,
you can just take the welfare instead of instead of making something of your
life,
you know,
and,
um,
that is what it is to kill a man when you kill his self determination and you
kill his,
his agency and you kill his motivation to do something with his life,
that is to kill a man.
And that is what the left is doing.
And,
and I say that's about that.
That is racism.
I do.
And,
and,
and we should say it out loud,
but we never do the conservatives never call it,
and they should call it what it is.
Um,
and you know,
well,
what can you do?
You just got to keep going.
Right?
What a beautiful ending.
That's it right there.
We're going to clip that one and do something with that.
Cause I was just barely,
well,
that this is what it's all about.
Everything that I'm trying to do here.
You're talking about the roots and the foundation of all that,
and you're doing it and I promise you I will make it to the school when I'm in
the UK for sure.
That'd be great.
Can I do a little something?
Can you give a little talk maybe or that'd be lovely.
We can do something.
They figured out that this was really a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
And thanks to Douglas by the way.
So we were used by Douglas Murray.
Yes,
yes.
No,
I know that everyone's your friend who dad was here for more on Catherine.
Follow her on Twitter.
It's at [inaudible] underscore snuffy.